in a moment we'll speak to a well-known
figurehead of these protests Joshua Wong
but here's more on Hong Kong's protest
movement since its handover to China in
1997 1997 the beginning of a new era in
Hong Kong the British colony was
returned to China under the principle of
one country two systems' it guaranteed
Hong Kong its own economic legal and
political systems for 50 years the
tensions underlying that principle have
soaked all the major protests in the
territory ever since China pushing for
one country Hong Kong protesters pushing
to protect their autonomy in 2003 on the
anniversary of the handover half a
million people turned out to demonstrate
against article 23 a national security
reform opponents feared the law would
threaten freedom of speech and assembly
freedoms non-existent in mainland China
the bill ended up being shelved more
than a decade later occupy central also
known as the umbrella movement propelled
a new generation of pro-democracy
activists to international prominence
they included then 17 year-old Joshua
Wong who is later among the leaders
convicted and jailed the activists at
the heart of the protest had already
been mobilizing for several years
spurred on by a crackdown on mainland
dissidents and concerns about Beijing's
encroachment into the territory a sit-in
to demand free elections last at 79 days
it was the most serious challenge to
Beijing's Authority in Hong Kong until
the protests that erupted in June this
year sparked by a proposed extradition
bill to allow suspects to be transferred
to mainland China activists have built
on the lessons learned during the
umbrella movement they've proved highly
organized using guerilla style tactics
as well as mass marches
and sit-ins the message they won't give
up Hong Kong's autonomy without a fight
and pro-democracy activist Joshua Wong
is with me in the studio
Joshua welcome and welcome to Berlin in
fact at an event last evening here in
the city you said and I quote if we are
in a new Cold War Hong Kong is the new
Berlin
unquote what did you mean by that under
the hotline of our Italian rule and
suppression in Hong Kong Hong Kong is
experienced police brutality and how
Beijing transformed my hometown to be a
police state and with our course on free
election we hope to let people to
understand that with the pressure of
Beijing and how the free world support
us Hong Kong is the new Berlin under the
new Cold War in what way are other
similar especially when we put into the
context of the trade negotiation of the
order chaos of the trade war between US
and China Hong Kong is on the front line
and the frontier to confront offer a
retiring rule of Beijing and expansion
of char power from China and I
experienced and observed the similarity
for what's happening in Berlin in last
century if you compare the two as you
are drawing parallels the protests in
Berlin and in other parts of Germany
were nowhere near violent as violent as
they are in Hong Kong where protesters
have essentially surrounded police
stations they've attacked police
officers why are the protests of violent
clash of violence exists or not it
depends more on police instead of the
site of protester three weeks ago on the
18th of August with 1.7 million citizen
John a peaceful but unauthorized
assembly and rally without any clash and
violence because police didn't storm
into the crowd in a long time yeah so if
clash or violence happen is strongly
related to the life-threatening weapon
used by riot police and I hope people
could realize that no one would enjoy to
see clash and violence happen but how to
make go and our question is where is
President Xi and Carrie Lam instead of
staying behind of riot police to allow
clash happen every week and
I just hope that aware that political
crisis must solve by political system
reform will come to that political
system reform I just like to talk a bit
about the violence if you're saying that
the protesters did nothing wrong why did
they apologize after the clashes at the
airport during the sit-in how we can
learn a lesson from every clash and
protest and to seek for international
community support is absolutely
important and significance I can't say
that in the past three months
I myself are free on 100% all the
behaviors of every protester especially
more than 2 million citizen join the
protest how can we expect that we agree
on 100 percent of all the behaviors but
at least instead of claiming on
activists we know that how Hong Kong
government and Beijing must be
accountable and responsible to solve the
political crisis and our ultimate goal
is not advocate on separatist ideology
we are asking for the fundamental right
we hope to vote in the election to elect
our government do you want a separate
Hong Kong we hope Hong Kong can under
autonomy and freedom and we are not the
one advocate on separatist ideology so
you do believe Hong Kong is a part of
China and one country two systems should
continue one country two system already
eroded with one country one and a half
system or now totally collapsed with
police brutality and transformed it to
be a police state we admit an aware Hong
Kong is under the rule of Beijing that's
why we are where our demand is sending a
message to Beijing government President
Xi you should hung Kong people to have
free elections that's the promise made
in the international treaty sino-british
joint declaration let's talk about how
the situation can be diffused now you
had Carrie Lam the Hong Kong chief
executive offer an olive branch a couple
of days back and she said let's engage
in dialogue it's something that she is
repeated today as well why do you all
not engage in dialogue on the one hand
Carrie Lam hold a press conference to
say that she welcomed dialogue on the
other hand she didn't reply the open
letter from pro-democratic ham lawmaker
Protima critique ham letter was written
long time Burke so since we sent the
letter to Carrie Lam and asked for a
dialogue on 1st of July till now none of
the government official really reply on
that latter and
concrete invitation to us and what we
are where is Caroline is not the
decision-maker and what we hope is apart
from withdrawing the bill before I born
in 1996 three decades ago Hong Kong
people are already demanding free
election so what is the response of
China and Hong Kong government on our
course on free election I'm just curious
you mentioned this thing about the open
letter you're not an open letter you
co-authored that letter to angular
Merkel before she traveled in China last
week the German government did not meet
you there nobody responded to that open
letter yet here you are in Germany and
you met Heiko Maas the Foreign Minister
I'm no surprise for them will not
directly reply on the letter but is a
good move for how the Chancellor and
Germany government pay attention to
what's going on in Hong Kong especially
emphasized the importance not to use
violence or not to use force to solve
the political crisis I know people may
have different idea insights or
perspective on the behavior of the
protesters side but more important thing
is if Beijing decided to imply the
martial law in Hong Kong which means the
emergency ordinance to shut down the
internet or public transport or send
troops to Hong Kong to allow what
happened in at Hanuman Square three
decades ago happen in Hong Kong again
that's not the way out and it's not
threatening only Hong Kong but also
global economy when we recognize Hong
Kong as the global financial center
Joshua Wong what should happen next what
do you want to see happen next we will
continue our protest with our course on
free election and condemn on police
brutality until 1st of October the
China's National Day what we are asking
for is just a promise made by Beijing in
the international treaty where you need
to elected our own government and now
it's time for President Xi to have
reflection it is due the way out to
conduct hotline policy to Hong Kong is
that deserve freedom and democracy we
leave it there for the time being just
show on thank you for coming in thank
you